I like that number 25 it's got some good
mojo in it al Jefferson is the last
warning for that number
Terry Rozier and the pack is not too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the pic of the world by Matisse five
here's that play again you can see the
pick-and-roll that's a nice bounce pass
to Ben young fellah drawn the defense
man catch it finish
[Applause]
two for one opportunity for the matching
if they work and right Scott getting a
piece of the rock it triggers the Sixers
Milton person to throw it down
what a catch with one hand by symmetry
possessions that he has regained for the
76ers two of them have led to buckets
ensued three a major Slam by Simmons
weaving his way
[Applause]
puttin the Sixers up 19 points take a
look at this action little pick and roll
Ben turns the corner and yeah not much
anybody can do they're able to split the
defense look at the eyes of the
quarterback asking for the screen and
then carving up the defense wounds and
rockets clogging him out
Richardson never hysteria mother look at
it as we take a look at shot goes up it
looks like it grazes the right side of
the rim hence making what Ben does to
follow completely legit yep and that
would tie the game his defense has been
pretty Stover this year hasn't it he's a
terrific defender bringing that smoke on
the putback it's going to be great at
everything and so we have to appreciate
what they're really good at and he's a
really good defender in an outstanding
passer and a terrific rebounder
[Applause]
Wow I'm sorry coach
big steps exhibit says Eric
[Music]
baby Rico's and he slams for two
Fitzsimmons first bucket of the third
corner that action again holiday on him
defenders late to get there and look at
it again holiday underneath he bought
the better of it Jim Boylan has changed
the system but right like they are now a
read and react offense it is pretty
strong himself
and watch them head of steam defender
right there he sharks him off like he's
not even there this is a big guy that's
a seven thank goodness that is
spectacular
that was a nice idea by Tyson because if
he would have been looking for it he
could out and see me watching it over
tights
this is just a great explosion hey when
he's coming from the right side of the
floor and he goes through his left once
he catches you there he plays the glass
or dumps it beautifully meaning the
injuries he has started an impressive
performance here by Trey young of the
Atlanta Hawks now Tatum for three
somebody's hit the floor after that that
dunk on the rebound the put back here by
Ben Simmons and then the fall down
[Applause]